[Music]
so one of the things that I think is
fascinating about all of what we're
talking about here is that it's not just
about gender and sex and sexuality but
this is also leaking into all sorts of
other things talking about ethnicity and
color of skin and all of that you've
written a bit about this I have yeah I
wrote about how university applications
in particularly Harvard has been
discriminating against Asians for
decades and to the point where Asians
when they apply to university will want
to hide their ethnicity in hopes of that
that's going to give them a fair chance
of actually getting into the school yeah
so all right so somebody that's watching
this right now that doesn't know about
this they're gonna go wait a minute why
would Harvard discriminate against Asian
people because apparently there are too
many Asians there if it's based solely
on SAT scores and meritocracy there's a
very high proportion of Asian students
and so in the name of quote-unquote
diversity and inclusion Asian students
get penalized so this to me is the most
blatant example of why this diversity
stuff is complete nonsense because
people are face value it seems nice we
want to help people we want to help
groups that maybe have struggled more
for whatever reason I think we should
and and there's probably many good ways
to do that maybe investing in more
education or whatever else I'm happy to
hear your thoughts on that but what they
take as a good thought then they don't
think all the way through which means
okay now we're gonna have to punish
people who have worked very hard and
done everything right and by and large
the Asian community whether it's Chinese
or Japanese or Korean or whatever else
have worked really hard and put a focus
on education and family and then what is
the result of that it's now harder if
not almost impossible at some level to
get into Harvard mmm-hmm and the
craziest thing I don't understand why
people think is this is acceptable and
even when I wrote that column I had a
number of Asians reach out to me and say
you know don't don't be used as a token
for the far right and I'm totally okay
with this this is fair and I'm thinking
what are you on I wasn't good at the
times do an op-ed I think by an Asian
woman if I'm not mistaken hmm yeah
saying that this is okay and I just I
mean what are you doing what do you do
it that you are fighting for true
equality yeah that is simply not what
they're fighting for
I think it's indoctrination at some
level I think especially for the kids
who are applying to these schools and
who are okay with having to score much
higher on the SAT in order to get a fair
chance I think they've just been told
you know this is how it has to be but
this idea that it should be equality an
equality of outcome as opposed to
opportunity is is silly and it doesn't
actually deal with actual differences in
terms of opportunity you know in terms
of the differences that we see and the
reasons why there are these differences
they're not actually being addressed
please tell me that you got some nice
support from members of the Asian
community and it wasn't just sort of
brainwashed lefties that were I didn't
know I didn't I got it across the board
of you know many races so I was grateful
for that because I wasn't sure how
people were going to respond to that
piece but I felt very strongly that I
had to say something has Harvard issued
a response to any of this or do we even
know where they're at with all this no
as far as I know that lawsuit is still
ongoing yeah it's just it really is just
crazy so I are you with me on this I
sense that there's some massive minority
groups that are breaking right now I
think the Asian community because of the
I hate saying community but you know you
have to use some words to describe some
of this but I think the black community
is breaking this is what a lot of what
Candis Owens is talking about I sense
this happening in the gay community I
sense this happening in the Jewish
community on very similarly the Asian
community have hard work and education
and all that so that you'd be decide we
have to put you at the bottom of the
oppression Olympics so there's an
interesting like strange Alliance now
now building up are you seeing that I
could say yeah I see it coming
I see well we were talking about the bit
about this earlier about how the left is
gonna eat its own until there is only
one person left so it's only a matter of
time really we're all gonna find each
other and say yeah we've had enough of
this I mean gay men you guys don't count
doesn't count to be
anymore so and I never wanted extra
credit I wanted equality equality I
wanted equal credit not extra credit
yeah so I'm in a weird way I'm actually
okay being thrown out in that regard of
this pyramid because I don't want to
play that game but I think actually
finally some gay men especially gay
white men because now they're they're
fully thought of as the enemy I mean
I've even seen things on college
campuses where LGBT organizations are
saying well you can't be a gay white man
and be the president of the organization
because you're you're one of the bad
guys I mean that that's really dangerous
thinking well I saw what you had to deal
with too with that professor who said
that the LGBT community doesn't want you
at the was at the University of
University of New Hampshire yeah do you
know that so I didn't know at the time
so I think much of my audience will know
what you're referring to but I spoke at
University of New Hampshire and they
were all these hecklers there and there
was a trans woman who I did not know was
a professor I didn't know that until
literally two months later who was was
screaming at me how much I hate trans
people all this and I kept saying I want
you to have equality under the law and I
want you to be treated with decency and
respect and I hope you find someone that
loves you all of the things I would want
for anyone else I just don't want the
government using dictating what pronouns
I can use to refer to you and you know
basically she was calling me all right
and all that and of course it turns out
she's a gender studies professor yeah I
should never be a surprise anymore
but there's gonna be no discipline at
the school or anything like that I mean
I could probably make more of a hey of
it and see what happens but it's like
yeah you know you handled it amazingly
well and works I mean it's only a matter
of time like I see with feminism they're
turning on white women now too so
it's insane is that the only logical
outcome of these disciplines because
they are not held to the scientific
standard of everything else that we
discussed here in the first half
that you that you are held to as a
scientist yeah I think because
everything is there's so much based in
subjective feeling and validating
people's experiences you apparently
can't question someone's experience so
if someone's offended or they don't like
you what can you say so I could see that
and it's it's very much rewarding people
for being emotionally driven instead
I think the best way to have a debate is
to remove emotion and just try to look
at the facts as objectively as you can
no matter what the issue is so it's that
it's that they don't really have any
sort of method to how they do their even
their researches I mean it's kind of a
joke yeah but are we kind of hearing
that even the methods now are part of
the patriarchy and all of those things
you're using facts they don't want facts
to actually count because they believe
in this postmodern drivel that that
facts have been arrived to by mechanisms
that they don't believe in that's it
that's a tough thing to trick somebody
out of yeah but you know I think on some
level I think some of these scholars
know that what they're doing is very
lucrative and so they're just basically
trying to shut people down in any way
they can they can't really justify it
but you know they just keep screaming
about it and academics who have better
things to do like actually do real
research and they've got their courses
and their students and a million other
things and they're 80-hour workweeks
they don't have time to deal with this
so this is why there's such a lopsided
discourse in terms of what you see
coming out of the universities and there
are some institutions that you know they
won't allow academics to engage with the
media without permission first so that
that's part of it too it's just it's
really an unfair battle right now that's
being fought yeah how do you think we
get to a place where specifically
related to sexuality and topics related
to gender and sex where we will be able
to talk about it in a in a better way so
for example the me2 movement where
everybody every I think basically
thinking person understands that there
were some really bad people here that
did some really bad stuff obviously
Harvey Weinstein and Bill Cosby and some
people that really that drugged people
and that you know years of history of
doing all this and then there's all
sorts of other people who seem like
they're just getting swept up in it or
basically accused or all that now you
can be for the idea of the me2 movement
without being for taking down all of
these other people also and I guess what
the real issue is is litigating
everyone's history where we could all
look back and go I did this someone did
that to me this that the other thing
college kids now have
and assign things before they hook up I
mean really where we're creating this
situation where our interpersonal
relations are going to have almost
nothing to do with the stuff that's
hardwired into us the stuff that you
study mm-hmm I think me too probably
started as something honorable and I do
agree that women and men have been
dealing with harassment for far too long
and that it doesn't get taken seriously
sometimes but it's to the point now
where relations are so strained
especially between men and women I sense
men are terrified and that's not going
to be helpful across the board for
anybody I think especially when you look
at shades of gray well I mean there's so
much I could say on this no best place
to start would be with consent say I
think one message that's been missing as
women I've read about this women need to
advocate for themselves and that's not
to say if you are experienced harassment
or if you were assaulted that you are at
fault I'm not advocating victim blaming
but I think what's missing from this
narrative women are portrayed as though
they're helpless and if something
happens to them they're helpless and
that they're basically they have no say
in terms of how men behave towards them
and you know I've written about sexism
in the sciences and how women are
basically being scared off I think of
going into the field as someone with a
PhD in a science field yeah you deal
with sexism and it's unpleasant but I
still got my degree and now I'm speaking
out about it so if you want to achieve
something you can a sexism it's not so
terrible in the world that women can't
achieve what they want so going back to
consent you know I think women need
young women especially you need to be
told you know you have a say in this if
you don't like something or if you don't
want to do something say so don't don't
feel like it's on the man - I don't read
your mind and I feel like I'm gonna get
in so much trouble for saying this but I
think that empowers women instead of
telling them you know just really hope
that this doesn't happen to you and if
it does then get on Twitter and use the
hashtag and talk about how men are
terrible and men are trashed men are not
terrible they're lovely men in the world
you know there are some bad men but you
can't generalize to all men yeah but we
love the generalization thing right I
mean you even see this the amount of
articles where I see you know we have to
take down white it's always white yeah
we have to take down or or now it's
women's turn to rule the world or all of
these things and it's like well a woman
could be president or a woman could be
you know anything that a man could be
but it shouldn't be because she's a
woman it should be because she's just
capable but but we've seen this sort of
hysterical reaction to it and I think
that that now is just another one of
these places where we're on this crazy
pendulum just bouncing back and forth
yeah I'm hoping it's going to come back
to the middle and hopefully not too much
damage will be done before that happens
and that the you know relations between
men and women aren't going to be so
terribly strained I do think we're
reaching that point though because there
are only so many men left who haven't
been accused of a me-too moment so no
it's only a matter of time you know it's
interesting I have a running joke with
some of my friends that I know a lot of
great straight girls in LA that are
single mm-hmm a lot of straight great
girls I don't know a lot of straight
guys that I think are great like I know
I know some straight guys that are
whatever but I don't know like a lot of
straight guys that kind of have their
[ __ ] together that are so I have all
these girls that are like oh can you set
me up with a guy and I'm like not guys I
know which does show that there's sort
of a crisis I think in masculinity or
something and obviously Jordan Peterson
is addressing this at some level
although now I've spent so much time
with him I think he's addressing it in a
certain way almost equally for men and
women although people only focus on the
male part but do you know is anyone
doing research on sort of what is
happening to young men in particular
right now hmm that's a good question I
know that levels of testosterone are
lower on average more recently so I
don't know if that has something to do
with it do we know what that what the
reasoning for that is could be maybe
there's more estrogens that are that
we're putting into our bodies trying to
think of what I can give you because
that's an interesting so how old are
your friends I'm curious this sort of
set of friends that I'm
these girls usually are in there sort of
like early 30s yeah kind of thing and
there and they're single which you know
most often cases a lot of them their
friends are married already
and like there they're on the hunt and
they've got good jobs and they look good
and they take care of themselves and all
of those things and I just don't see the
equivalent here mm-hmm
I don't maybe there's an odd subset of
because la is like a little bit of an
odd place maybe there's more gay people
here I don't know exactly yeah I mean I
could see the average age for people
getting married is 28 so I don't want to
I don't want to generalize and say that
across
what do you Sciences want to be fair
yeah yeah but I mean it could be that
for guys who are a certain age if
there's a reason but at the same thing
for women of a certain age and not to
say that you're friends of course but
you know if you're focused on your
career maybe you're not used to giving
your time to someone else that could be
part of it yeah yeah do you think that
the feminist movement which I know is
sort of we've sort of ancillary been
talking about it this whole time that
they really did give up something very
special by putting so much focus on work
and success in that way I mean you know
I think back to my childhood now which I
think in retrospect was so amazing my
mom was home for most of it she worked
before I'm the oldest of three she
worked before I was there and then she
didn't work all the years that she was
raising us and then went back to work
after and that having someone at home
that was cooking and taking care of us
and making sure we got to school and all
of those things like that's like the
greatest thing that anyone could do it
happens to more often be the woman but
that's a that's a pretty great thing
that's often been sacrificed now we're
thought of it it's mocked in a way now
yeah I mean I've always been a typical
in terms of I've always been felt more
masculine I've always been very focused
in my career but I definitely think that
feminism and for some people or some
proponents of feminism they will
denigrate female typical roles and
motherhood and wanting to be you know at
home with your family and I think you
know I've heard from women who say I've
been told that the path to happiness is
for me to focus on my career and
to neglect my personal life and and then
they reach a point where they realize no
I do want those things and I don't think
there should be anything wrong with that
and the same thing you know I've written
about how there's such an emphasis for
for girls to be like boys now I saw you
tweet about babies yeah babies and
underlined that is a sexism that you
know says that girls need to be like
boys in order to be equal or worthy of
respect and no one's talking about that
where people are just saying yeah
for sure let's just you know tell girls
that they have to be the same as boys
and women have to be the same as men
yeah so the article you're referring to
it there was this piece I think was in
Newsweek that these parents are raising
their twins as babies th ey babies
babies because and they're gonna let
them pick their gender mm-hmm and it's
like you're gonna create more
psychological problems than you were
trying to hide them from most likely I
think yeah and it goes back to biology
again and hormonal exposure in utero
yeah I think it's great that he might
have been NBC News I think that means
okay yeah yeah but I think there are a
couple outlets that were so excited
about this and the whole that's what it
without was why I wrote about it not
because of the thing you know these
parents can do whatever they want that's
what I followed up with immediately
after parents could do whatever they
want and then when the children are of
age they can either decide my parents
were crazy or not right this is on the
parents right and all that but but that
wasn't the issue for me it was that the
way these headlines are always written
it's like that this it was like this is
the new thing and the implicit piece of
that is you better do this yeah to be a
good parent and tolerant parent to be a
progressive parent and that is
open-minded person and that to me is the
danger here
not the little isolated case necessarily
of these people that are doing something
that's an outlier thing yeah and and the
thing is I've heard stories now where
people are terrified of giving their
daughters dolls and which is what's
really funny is you have some of these
really progressive parents who raised
their girls they only have
gender-neutral toys or they give them
boys toys and then the girl obviously
goes to school and sees girl typical
toys and wants to play for them and the
parents are horrified and they think oh
this is the patriarchy coming in the
return of the Patriots just biology and
we shouldn't be a
and we shouldn't we shouldn't shame
girls for wanting to be female typical
yeah but this is why when people say I
think to a bunch of us that are in this
space
oh you guys are overstating what this
thing is it's just a bunch of angry
activists or whatever it's like we've
seen it in fact academia which you
addressed already we've seen it in fact
the home and how you're supposed to
raise your kids even just thinking about
this now it's like I think I'd read
something on this and if not there's
definite proof of it that Disney made a
decision along the way now that they
have Star Wars and Marvel that Star Wars
was going to be more marketing to girls
and Marvel was going to be the boys
thing now I'm a big Star Wars guy and I
would see these commercials and it was
all girl you know girls in the ships and
girls with the lightsabers like I have
no problem with that
obviously rave a leading character and
last one is a girl it's all good that
girls can do it I love but but pushing
marketing on them seems odd to me and
and although I'm sure there are many
girl girls out there that want to be
Jedi there's obviously more boys so the
way that we even mark it and I suspect
they're marketing in a way that's
hurting their bottom line in the name of
tolerance in the name of what I don't
know yeah so I mean how did the boys
feel about that right right so you're
gonna get this odd thing then when
eventually it if they're enough
marketing boys are gonna want to play
with the girl thing and then feel weird
about it
god that's messed too much time they do
have too much time on their hands yeah I
just say let kids do what they want and
acknowledge that as long as you give
them free choices you probably won't
have too much say at the end the day but
at least you know they they'll be happy
yeah is there anything else that you're
researching at the moment or that's been
on your mind that that we haven't
covered the only thing I would say is so
with wrong speak we are gonna be
launching our site we just launched our
first season yeah last month so we spoke
with James Tim or Lindsey Shepard we
also did an episode on rapid onset
gender dysphoria so it's this phenomenon
of adolescent girls who were suddenly
saying they're transgender even though
they've had no previous signs of gender
dysphoria and actually their problems
have nothing to do with gender so so
what are the problems that's just
societal stuff or pressure
wanting attention or all of the above
usually autism as well so they either
will be diagnosed by a mental
professional but the person will say I
can't say that I have to you know affirm
your child's gender because they can
otherwise get a lot of trouble and lose
their jobs that they don't really you
repeat that identical right so that they
will lose their jobs if they don't know
but they they have to affirm their yeah
they have to clinicians nowadays have to
affirm these kids if a child says
they're transgender you have to they'll
lose their jobs otherwise so so
technically a therapist or a clinician
could feel that this is some other issue
going on nothing but they have to
actually affirm what the child says yeah
the parents and in all the documents
yeah because they will lose their jobs
they're terrified and so in Toronto what
happened but what the Preston case was
my colleague Kenneth sucker
I had a clinic where he saw gender
dysphoria and people said that he was
practicing conversion therapy he was not
so conversion therapy I do not stand for
it's trying to turn gay children
straight but sexual orientation is not
the same thing as gender so gender and
young children is flexible and it
becomes more stable with age so when he
when patients would come to him and say
you know I want to be the opposite sex
he would say okay what's the objection
when you say gender is taxable you don't
mean the amount of genders you mean the
female that you have related to gender
sex I just want to be clear so if you
have an example you've been using if you
have a little boy who says he's a girl
he will likely be a gay man and he will
likely grow to be comfortable in his
male gender identity so for 99% of us
our biological sex is our gender man
this this thing it's it's a real monster
yeah there's a lot of misinformation out
there so no what I was saying with my
colleague his clinic got shut down he
wasn't doing anything unethical but
because of that it set this chill across
the field now clinicians do not do not
want to have the same thing happen to
them because activists will go after
them yeah so there's no one really
practice
saying or anyone sort of thought of his
legitimate that's practicing conversion
therapy anymore is there I hope not
and and all the sciences against it like
the that it just never worked like it
was just something that I guess sort of
twisted ideologue was practicing not
using real evidence or science and yeah
I mean they just fizzled out basically
yeah I do think there are some
practitioners who are still doing it not
I wouldn't call them legitimate which it
makes me very uncomfortable when I see
that but yeah definitely sexual
orientation is biological its genetic
and it can't be changed
so conversion therapy is completely
useless yeah well I'm glad we got there
at least I think I think most people
won't be angry at you on that one well I
guess maybe some people on the right may
be might be angry maybe but you know I'm
all about presenting the data and
speaking to facts and the science and
standing up for sex research whether it
infuriates people on the left or the
right yeah science facts reason pretty
much pretty much all but all sort of
package within within the free speech
thing yeah can I call you a member of
the intellectual dark web please do I
don't know that I have that power but
I'm gonna go back to the clubhouse later
get me a membership yeah yeah you know
we have to vote on it I can be a white
man some days yeah oh right that was the
thing it was like they you know whatever
all these idiots that are writing all
these nonsensical pieces about it's all
white man and it's like they're a bunch
of us that are not white but I mean they
call I've been called a white
supremacist I've been called a Nazi so
you know that's the level that we're at
right now and they have nothing else so
I think it's a good sign in a weird way
it absolutely is a good time well it's
been a pleasure I'm so glad that we
finally got to do this it's so much fun
yeah we will we will do I sense these
issues are not going away
so we're gonna have to do this again all
right very good for more on Deborah you
can follow her on Twitter it's at
Deborah's ill
[Music]
you